uh there's only one solution smashing
the like button disbanding oh okay yeah
oh yeah okay yes that's right i was
gonna i was gonna i was gonna say
ladies and gentlemen it is time to
disband the democratic party
we must remove every name image and
political group
that has engaged in the atrocity of
slavery that's right
starting with the democratic party
they're saying that they want to bring
all the statues down because
you know the confederate flag because it
reminds them of slavery well
you know what on that note why don't you
go ahead and lead us in
from abc news gop member
introduces resolution banning the
democratic party
so how funny is this adam comes to me
he's like did you hear the republicans
are trying to ban the democratic party
and i was like what shut up oh what new
babylon b
huh funny yeah adam's like no no i i
mean it there's
there's like a couple guys they're
trying to ban the democratic party and i
was like
what and i was like well hold on you
adam you explained it to me
because the democrats were the party of
slavery jim crow and the clan i went oh
i agree yeah ban him get right i'm
kidding
it's written it's it's it's funny you
get the point they're making
yeah they literally they literally
drafted a resolution to ban the
democratic party of course it's not
going to happen but could you imagine
what would happen if the republicans
controlled the house the senate and the
executive branch
and the supreme court i bet the riots
would stop
um maybe no i don't i don't know maybe
yeah probably because but there were
there was
writing under obama like all the black
lives matter stuff started under obama
yes they did yeah and that that's him
that's him and joe biden that's the
craziest thing about all these riots
it's like joe biden you were you were in
office and this is going on you're not
gonna solve the problem you're gonna
make it worse
it's gotten worse and worse so why
should we think you're going to do it
you know
yeah so everyone likes to say this is by
this is going to be biden's america
no trump is in charge right now this is
trump's america and he's like no no no
no this started
under obama and biden's administration
trump is deploying federal
law enforcement to stop it yeah he's and
he's making laws
and executive orders that are reversing
a lot of the things that they've done
well let's let's let's read this real
quick all right so from abc they say
u.s rep louis gomer introduced a
resolution to ban
any political party that has been
supportive of slavery which he says
includes the democratic party the texas
republican also calls for house speaker
nancy pelosi to remove any items that
symbolize or mention
any political party that supported
slavery or the confederacy
as outlined in the resolution a great
portion of the history of the democratic
party is
filled with racism and hatred since
people are demanding we rid ourselves of
the entities symbols
and reminders of the repugnant aspects
of our past then the time has come for
democrats to acknowledge their party's
loathsome and bigoted past
and consider changing their party name
to something that isn't so blatantly and
offensively tied to slavery
jim crow discrimination and the clan
gomer said in a statement
he's right he is if they're saying ban
the flag the confederate flag that's
being banned is the battle flag it's not
even the flag of it's not even the
actual flag of the confederacy
it's a it was the battle flag ah yeah
so if they're saying take that down
because the confederates were losers
the statues have to go well okay
the the politicians who claim to be
democrats yeah well they're they're
still elected officials but the name
should go right you know i read into i
was reading an article about
when the statues all went up and it was
after they lost
oh way after yeah way later it was like
what was it was like the daughters of
the confederacy or something
yeah something like that so so a lot of
it was to try to repair
the the ties from the south to the north
it was right it was the
optimized yeah it was the union saying
look you lost here's
you know put up some statues so you can
at least you know have um
be proud of of you know i you know i'm
not
i'm not saying be proud of slavery part
because that's what everyone wants to
jump to they're like
oh well that's what it's about they they
miss having their slaves and it's like
no no they don't they like we talked
about it
most people didn't even want to be in in
this you know the war
you know they thought that it wasn't
even going to be a thing i don't think
like you can trace back the tensions
all the way back to the civil war yeah i
mean even before it mm-hmm
it's kind of crazy that like i was
looking at some congressional
seats and the history and it's a weird
thing that happened right around the
time of the civil war it became a
two-party system
yeah it was and it was it was very much
so based around slavery
with the republican party being like no
it's time to end it yeah and the
democrats being like how dare you
and throughout the throughout the past
hundred plus years
it has there's that animosity still
existed
that's that that split that divide for a
long time the democrats were very
very very racist absolutely they and
they
they still are bro right right so what i
was gonna say is they claim
they claim the great switch happened
which is not true it's way more
complicated to say something like that
but that's not the case
and i'm gonna tell you right now the
democrats have never been more racist in
my opinion
when when they come out and straight up
say the things they've been saying
woke yeah you know the intersectionalism
it's hardcore white supremacy to claim
that white people invented scheduling
yeah like hard work right
exactly it's it's to claim that white
culture like hard work is white culture
is
insanely white supremacist agreed it's
so there's that there's a comedy sketch
going around from uh ryan long
and yeah it's it's it's amazing he's got
like millions of views by now
but it's two guys who are best friends
and one's woke and one's racist and it
turns out they agree on almost
everything
everything almost everything about the
very end yeah at the very end that white
people are the root of all evil he says
so the point is is clear like if the
democrats are
embracing now intersectionalism which is
in my opinion like overtly
white supremacist what's your promises
with guilty consciences basically yeah
then they've not changed at all the only
thing they're doing now is
instead of fighting against minorities
they're claiming to represent them
and then it's like you got you gotta
hand it to a man it's clever
if you want to sabotage somebody let me
tell you a story how do you guys like to
hear a story
i do i do i do i do i want to hear a
story let me tell you a story of one of
the cleverest
murders i've ever heard about oh my so
there's a story based in illinois
about a man who had gotten away with
murder several times
okay and you know how he did it i don't
he didn't go
up to the people he hated and murder
them because people would have noticed
either a fight broke out
or he went missing oh he was very smart
you see what he would do is he would
find a bar
near a body of water he would invite his
rival for a drink where he was going to
apologize
he'd get the individual very very drunk
and then they would walk out of the bar
towards the body of water and he would
go
right into the water and then he would
call for help help please
help and the guy black out drunk falls
in the water and drowns
and then once the people come he's
screaming for help but he's the one who
called for help
he certainly didn't do anything wrong my
friend and i got really drunk and he
fell in
oh no i need help and it was only after
apparently some cop noticed
that that a bunch of these stories had
popped up about a guy who was calling
for help when his friends were drowning
and he put two and two together yeah and
was like
wait a minute it turns out he had fights
with these people
so so the reason i bring this up is this
dude learned a very clever way to get
away with committing a crime
was to feign being friends with the
person and then sabotage them
i see what you're doing you're talking
about the democrats right that's right
they started pretending like they're the
good guys listen to us we'll do all the
good things for you and then did a bunch
of bad things
yeah and they're and so chicago there's
no better example than chicago you're
right
that's true chicago has been under
democrat world for like 80 years for a
long time yeah
and it has some of the worst uh
segregation some of the worst violent
crime
gang activity they've solved nothing at
the very least we can say
they are completely incapable of
governing a city
yeah let alone anything else yeah they
straight up took all
all low-income housing from the entire
north side of the city
and just bulldozed it all and just
forced everyone to go
fend for themselves on the south side of
chicago
and then what happened on the south side
of chicago what did we just find out
like uh was like a month ago
well so so uh the area i grew up in i
was looking at google maps
and i was trying to show like here's the
area and here's like the the project
housing
yep and i noticed the very strange thing
on google maps there was nothing but
fields
fields with open surround surrounded by
fences and signs saying private property
you know no no entry
and then i went you can go back in time
to earlier years
and i went back about nine years and all
of a sudden all the project houses were
back
the city literally raised the entire
project on the south side by my house
yeah
just wiped it all out yeah and i've
looked into it like that kind of thing
it's like
so there was lots of of gang violence in
chicago there still is a lot of gang
violence in chicago and a lot of the
reasons why it's getting worse
or it was getting a lot worse i i mean
now it's obvious reasons um but
it's because they were pushing everyone
together like all the gangs from the
north side
got pushed down to the south side and
now they're getting rid of more housing
projects so people are getting more and
more condensed on top of each other
fighting each other and killing each
other i welcome donald trump sending the
feds in chicago
to be fair too absolutely i don't live
there anymore for these reasons
but trump said some fbi dea atf
like atf especially man on the south
side with the gun crime
yeah this is what i was saying before
like we mentioned this the other day if
if i went out and i saw
you know the cbp guys with the tactical
gear i'd be like whoa
crazy and it's happened before i've seen
that in chicago where it's like a bunch
of cops come out and like swat
and then we call friends like whoa what
happened did you see the police that's
crazy
you want to get some nachos from
7-eleven yeah right like nobody cares
because we're not going around smashing
windows and starting fires
and when i was in ferguson during the
riots
when we were leaving the national guard
was staging like a few blocks away
and we walked up and saw some national
guard we're like how's it going
everybody and they're like hey what's up
we're like what's going on and we just
chatted for a little bit
because they're people yeah and they
were like yeah they're worried you know
if things really got at hand you know
we'll be here trying to keep things calm
we just want people to be safe and i'm
like i hear you
and we talked about the nuances of a
riot and how people protest and how it
escalates
and we basically grin a lot of things
they were cool dudes we all i also
talked to some cops and they were saying
like basically the same things now i'll
tell you what though i saw some
some i saw cops do some bs in ferguson
yeah like walking up for no reason and
chucking a flashbang at
people just doing literally nothing and
it sparked a riot i've seen that kind of
stuff happen
right so i mean um we we've discussed it
there's
are there bad cops yeah yes there are
right yeah i mean okay are there bad
people
yeah are there racists in the world the
real issue is that there are bad people
period period thank you and the issue is
when it comes to police
police should be held to a certain
standard you know what i mean by that is
if they're the enforcers of the law
then we need to make sure we don't have
like we need a set of standards that we
don't have bad people who gain that
power
it's going to happen you know and that's
what we got to be very careful of that's
true because then they'll start bringing
in their buddies
they'll start infecting you know certain
you know like chicago is
so corrupt man yeah you get it it gets
bad
so anyway we're supposed to be talking
about banning the democratic party but
to bring it back to chicago
we've got there was there's some there's
so much corruption in chicago there was
a video
years ago of like a bunch of off-duty
cops beating up a waitress yeah
there was a cop who grabbed a meter maid
by the throat and slammed up against the
wall because she gave
the cop a ticket for illegally parking
it's messed up it's a dirty city man
it is and i feel bad i feel bad for the
cops you know who the good cops
or or the rookie cops were like i want
to be a cop man i want to do the right
thing
and they get in and you've got do you
know the story of john burge
no i don't i don't know it sounds
familiar just be very careful but google
it this dude was accused of
electrocuting people into forced
confessions
whoa chicago is a very place again
a democratic city for like like a
century almost a century yeah
exactly so that's why it's like i think
you know i've talked about this before
my bias against the democrats is
probably somewhat part of this where
i grew up in a city where republicans
were not a factor where it was like the
republicans did things that i didn't
didn't affect me yeah they'd talk about
pro-life and you know flat tax or
whatever and i'd be like oh
and the war stuff definitely i was like
oh these neocons
and then you have the democrats in
chicago that just ran everything like it
was a wasteland it was like
it was just awful and so i've i've been
personally betrayed
by these politicians they've they've
promised things we've worked that you
know i'm not gonna get in specific
details
but there were some certain certain
instances where we were prom made
promises by the city
in exchange for fundraising and work and
then they just like basically
figuratively knifed us in the back yep
and so i'm like i hate this place it's
crooked it's corrupt
the violence is out of hand i'm done
with this so
you know what man you get you reap what
you sow
louis gohmert has proposed this bill and
i don't believe it specifically targets
the democratic party
i believe it just targets the idea of
racist
parties yeah well that's the or the
idea of that they can just apply this
blanket
racist you know statement on all these
different things you know like all the
statues and all the
whatever else they're they're claiming
is is racist nowadays
it's not it doesn't work there's a point
where they're going to be like
oh wait a minute this is now coming back
to bite us and we we should
you know cancel that well if uh if the
republicans sweep the house and the
senate the first thing they can do is
say in honor
of intersectionalism we think we should
take down any symbol
representing slavery and the first thing
on that list
is the democratic party boom yep
you reap what you sow thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you